what is your okay how long have you been
in LA full time it's been about a year
I've been out here for like I moved out
here like five months ago okay so you've
been out here five months
give me your favorite restaurant in La
that you've had that reminds you because
I feel like New York has some of the
best restaurants I think specifically
some of the best Asian food that I've
ever had is in New York City right have
you have you found a place here that
reminds you of some food back home or
that is just kind of like your go-to yet
is different the Chinese the Asian food
here is different and I miss New York
food I ain't gonna lie I miss New York
food
um but the Asian food let's talk about
the Asian food the Asian food is
different than New York first of all
y'all in La don't have the the staple
like Chinese Hood spot I don't I ain't
see it like maybe they got them but I
know for sure I probably just ain't
going the right neighborhood but you
know in New York every block you got a
staple Chinese Hood spot you know what
I'm saying chicken wings fried rice with
the Duck Sauce you know what I'm saying
out here
I I don't you know I mean I don't think
yeah they don't really do that out here
like that I miss that you know I mean uh
oh they they have better like hot pot
and like real Chinese like Chinese food
Chinese food in terms of like you know
out here out here they have better like
like real Chinese food but they're like
corn you know it's funny because we were
in Canarsie with the dusty Locane and
shout out to Dusty man and he freeze
Dusty he did he took us straight to the
the Chinese spot and I think I had like
a
did you have the chicken wings frog yeah
the chocolate like they chopped up the
chicken wings yeah yeah and then it was
with the fried rice yeah the Duck Sauce
that's exactly that's that's like when
you said that bro that's literally what
I ate yeah a little soy sauce soy sauce
for the rice duck sauce on it no duck
sauce on the rice you know what I'm
saying soy sauce on the chicken and the
rice oh my God yeah it was a great spot
it was like it looked like it's a place
that like they don't do that out here
yeah yeah for sure yeah
somewhere but I don't know I mean yeah
but like you know so I know I know the
area you're staying in a lot of stuff
over there is like nice yeah yeah yeah
yeah they got it they got they got nice
stuff but I'll be traveling all around
throughout L.A but I just don't see that
but then you know they got better Asian
food when it comes to like real Asian
food like you know what I'm saying hot
pot and stuff like that I feel like the
food is there's more Asian people here
well you know what I fell in love with
in La is uh
oh my God you gotta you gotta go to
Orange OC to get the [__] I I there's a
spot there did you go to the place
that's in the like kind of like in that
mall
there's like a mall of just food in the
orange yeah yes
insane yeah oh my God what yo the fall
here is amazing bro the fun New York I
would never eat the food and the and the
ramen man the ramen is crazy yeah come
on LA's got great food I ate some spicy
I did a spicy Ramen challenge yesterday
[__] my [__] I was [__] Peppers oh
no